the NFL has been taking the position for
the past few weeks Chris that the league
plans to play full season full stadiums
and there hadn't really been any
acknowledgment of a contingency plan
well someone from the league leaked to
the Washington Post yesterday and and it
happens a lot and the fingerprints are
there when it's the league office
leaking information that it wants out to
The Washington Post and The Washington
Post is one of the preferred
destinations for the news that the
league office wants to have out there in
the public mainstream so the news that
was leaked yesterday to the Washington
Post is this
there are contingency plans in place and
we have wondered aloud are there
contingency plans they're not saying
they're contingency plans maybe they
should have them those contingency plans
include a shortened season and Peter
King is spit balled on the possibility
of 14 games or 12 games also the NFL
planning for empty stadiums or partially
filled stadiums that checkerboard
concept Chris that you and I talked
about a couple of weeks ago where you
can have people in the stands they just
can't be on top of each other and I
don't know logistically how you get the
people into the stands think of how long
it's going to take to get in how long
it's gonna take to get out do you have
to wait to go to the bathroom until the
person in the row behind you has gone I
mean you because even if you're seated
at a safe distance
there's no way to ensure you're gonna
constantly be at a safe distance when
you go get a hotdog or a pretzel or
whatever so there's a lot of questions
and that's the thing every answer we get
here raises more questions yeah we get
any type of guidance about what they're
thinking I can come up with five to ten
more questions like that
that they need to resolve as well but at
least they're identifying these
contingencies and they're they're
planning for them and hopefully
internally they're spotting the
questions that arise from every
potential plan answering them then more
questions come up answer those and you
just keep doing it until you've answered
all the possible questions yeah I mean I
don't envision seeing fans in the
stadium at all early in the year if we
can make it happen
I don't you know one for some of the
reasons you just talked about I think
people would be reluctant
to go there and be around that many
people in a public forum like that I
just don't see that happening but the
great thing is you know okay Mike I mean
you know what's your feel of watching a
football game without fans in the
stadium you know it's a sport that we
know can financially still thrive
without fans in the stadium it's
different than baseball and basketball
we're not dependent on an 82 or 162 game
seasons like they are that's the big
moneymaker for them the actual you know
in season ticket crowd sales the NFL
that's not the case the majority the
money is coming from TV and other
avenues to where you know I think
financially the NFL can still be good
and the ratings would be through the
roof if they could do it but you know
Mike I mean I don't know if I've really
heard you said this what's your thoughts
if you had a watch Vikings you know
Vikings Bears with no no spans in the
stadium well first of all I'm not ready
to sign on to your idea that it's no big
deal to lose the box office receipts
well but you're talking about a lot of
money
I haven't crunched the numbers but I
think we're talking about a lot of money
that it's law so of course you don't
have fans in the stadium's how do you
make that back you can't unless you're
gonna play games on Saturdays too if
college football isn't played and you
you come up with new TV deals on the fly
right right that's one way you can make
some of the back but it could wreak
havoc on the salary cap for 2021 if we
have a dramatic reduction in the amount
of money they make from the fans who
show up and watch the games or don't and
and yeah I was watching the other night
the first Brett Favre game against the
Packers when he played for the Vikings
in 2009 and there were crowd reactions
after every big play the blowing of the
horn you know you strip all that stuff
out it's just gone what would it be like
what would it sound like you would hear
a lot of ambient noises coming from the
players that I think I'd be very
fascinating but you know we talked about
this yesterday Chris when big cat was on
Kirk Cousins made comments earlier this
week
suggesting that from his perspective it
would be refreshing to not have the
crowd noise and really when you think
about it at home as a quarterback you
don't have a whole lot of noise when
you're trying to go up to the line of
scrimmage and figure out what you want
to do on the road it becomes deafening
in certain places you take that out of
the equation yeah I don't care about
playing in Seattle or New Orleans
because I can at least hear myself think
and I can let my offensive teammates
know what I'm doing
well definitely I mean I think there are
some positives like you said we're gonna
hear players say things that you know
hey listen they might not be for kids
you know 14 and under but it's gonna be
some interesting language we're gonna
pick up on the NFL football field you
can always pump in crowd noise if that's
what we wanted to do just to make us all
feel a little bit more you know normal
watching a football game so that's the
possibility no no that's like putting a
laugh track on a sitcom let's we do not
need just throwing it out there I don't
want that either
I wanna hear Tom Brady cussed out his
offensive linemen when they don't pass
protect him or Aaron Rodgers yelling at
a receiver for running the run I mean
this to me that would be entertaining
let alone Mike my biggest thing is you
want to talk about a psychoanalysis
experiment I mean I would really be
intrigued to see which guys can bring
themselves up to a level of intensity
with no fans there as compared to the
guys that you know hey listen at a 50
tube man locker room thirty two of the
guys thirty five of the guys they love
football they're in on it they live it
this is what they do but you do have a
faction of guys who they just play
football they don't go home and watch
Monday Night Football or Sunday Night
Football with the days over they just
show up and do their job they like
playing the game but they're not
emotionally invested in it like likewise
all the time and that to me would be
entertaining as well to see who could
rise to the occasion and who doesn't and
I think there are plenty of guys who
would trade not having fans in the
stands for home games if it means not
having fans in the stands for road games
it's eight times a year you're walking
into a hostile environment some more
hostile than others and they're yelling
at you they're taunting
you there swearing at you they're
dumping beer on you you take that out of
the mix you got you got not
significantly less stress as a football
player because there are still plenty of
ways to be stressed out and plenty of
demands and expectations but you take
those opposing crowds out of the mix and
your life gets a little bit easier so
who knows how that's gonna play out and
Chris again
more questions because I I think when we
get back to the point where it's okay
for people to attend these games that
doesn't mean they're going to you're
gonna have people give up season tickets
they've had for years you're gonna have
waiting lists evaporate you're gonna
have issues with sellouts and one last
point before we take a break yeah when
dr. foul she came out and said recently
that Sports can return if teams are
quarantined and stadiums are empty you
know that that's that Arizona concept
we've heard for baseball and I've spit
balled the idea of taking all the teams
in the NFL to some remote location and
keeping them there for the season
there's gonna be some players who say
I'm not doing it I'm just like that's
yeah plenty will plenty will the ones
without families the young guys without
families who cares but the people who
have spouses and kids they are not gonna
want to be away for four months so even
though that's a practical way to get a
season in you're gonna have plenty of
players with highly recognizable names
who say thank you but no thank you I'm
not I'm not gonna do well what if
they're just quarantined to the way they
are right now but yet they can go to the
football facility and then they get to
go back home right I mean I'm just
posing questions here you know just to
see where that goes and if you're doing
strict testing of the whole organization
on a weekly basis and everybody can
still live their life to where okay
we're going to the football facility but
after you have to go home and continue
with the quarantine and the social
distancing you know these are things do
to me like the NFL needs to start right
now getting out and like polling the
players and the organizations and the
coaches and the front office people how
comfortable would you be if we did this
how comfortable would you be if we did
that you know they have to start gauging
how this ago you know me I want to see
it happen because I'm selfish yes but -
I think it would be a great band-aid for
America I really do I think by the time
August and September come around we
are gonna be starved for something and I
think a lot of NFL players are not
intimidated by coal bid 19 now you know
again I'm just speaking for myself when
I was 26 27 28 years old I would just be
like let's go play football and I think
a lot of guys would have that mindset
but I know that's not in totality and we
got to get a feel for that keep this in
mind though they're gonna have to talk
to the Union the union's gonna have to
agree right
and whatever they do whatever they do
they're gonna have to come up with a way
to let guys opt out without some sort of
draconian financial penalty and for some
guys maybe they'll say I don't want my
salary this year I'm fine I choose not
to play these guys another thing that I
think is gonna make the players want to
play what that right there some guys
Michael we always talk about they only
go I only got four year career here I
need to strike him play I'll play I
don't give a damn I need the money you
know and I think a lot of 24 25 year old
guys would think like that and that's
where you know it gets intriguing in a
good conversation you're right we got to
talk to the NFLPA and get these
conversations going
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports